ec rennaise ce journaliste libération
d'un mac guêpier auteur notamment de
serial fucker journal d'un bear becker
en 2003 aux éditions blanche où vous
expliquer comment plomber un partenaire
tout à fait donc ça c'était un roman
donc je suis venu il ya un an et demi
expliqué les problèmes du bareback dans
la communauté gay j'ai fait mon j'ai
fait mon devoir de renseignements et de
l'information
je suis journaliste donc depuis 15 ans
je bossais à guêpier cantier quand
didier était un guêpier aussi après j'ai
fait les articles dans je suivais les
élisent à bhl d'act up de pourprée
ration donc j'ai toujours fait un
travail de prévention c'est à dire qu'à
un moment on pouvait vous soupçonnez de
faire l'apologie du bareback en
expliquant exactement comment il fallait
faire pour couper le bout de la capote
pour faire un trou avec une aiguille
pour être sûr de contaminer son
partenaire et aujourd'hui vous dit en
fait j'ai fait tout ça pour pour
certains les interventions c'est un
travail de journaliste que j'avais fait
aussi jeudi ce qui se passe exactement
dans certaines backrooms comme comme
didier le fait est là mais en fait
d'accord avec ça l'idée une ans c'est
trop facile d'écrire des trucs dans les
bouquins et ne pas faire télé pour dire
c'est juste un roman je veux dire tous
les [ __ ] qui connaissent et connaissent
érik rémès vont sur son site et c'est
qu'il est il sait ce qu'il a écrit
il a encore donné une interview un temps
où disait que ça fait plusieurs années
qu'ils baiser sans capote acquis choper
elles toutes les messes et du monde
qu'est ce qui se sont contaminées et qui
disait grosso modo que c'était tout à
fait cool je faisais là c'est moi si je
suis choisi la tension excusons
sincèrement vous avez dit attendre grâce
à matri train d'oublier tout ça donc je
vous permets de faire ce que je veux
c'est vrai vous l'avez écrit dans cette
nuit a écrit bien sûr j'ai le droit de
parler d'eux
de ce qui me plaît aussi faire baiser
sans capote et dans le iv est alors
beaucoup de militants d'act up ont visé
sans cape breton si la maj moi je suis
là je suis pas là pour parler du sida
toute façon je suis en plus je ne
préfère pas parler avec didier lestrade
puisqu'il ya quoi parce que dans la
mesure où je parle pas aux fascistes de
manière généralement on me dit pas c'est
que ça reste
et oui c'est un fasciste et deuxièmement
c'est yahia donc j'ai d'accord avec ce
procédé à une procédure judiciaire parce
que act up a saccagé les bureaux de mon
éditeur ou des éditions blanche et donc
il ya une procédure en cours dont je
veux pas je passe je vais pas parler de
ce à quoi tient un schisme dans la
communauté est grave mais c'est trop
facile ça c'est trop facile c'est à dire
que pendant des années vous savez à
chaque fois que j'ai sorti un bouquin il
me disait merci d'avoir parlé de moi
parce que tu as fais ma promo donc il
faut pas être aussi cynique que ça c'est
à dire le mec il a fait vraiment son
beurre sur le bareback il ya des gens
qui ont lu ses bouquins et il ya
sûrement des gens qui sont devenus
séropositifs aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
sont tellement désemparé qu'ils ont
pensé que c'était une option possible
d'affronter le sida ancs se comptent en
minant d'une manière voulue et vous
maintenant on est en train de dire que
c'est des romans c'est trop facile tu as
le même discours que tu as mais n'en ont
l'air on nourrit les gens sur le fait de
moi je suis drôlement même j'ai toujours
dit la même chose
non mais moi je sais c'est que j'ai pas
un double discours mais c'est vrai aussi
didier vous vous conviendrez que en
dehors des romans et notamment serial
fucker le le roman de notre ami rms le
plus grand sex shop gay de paris m un
rayon de vidéos bareback donc il n'est
pas le seul responsable comme moi et
j'ai fait des articles dans têtu pour
dénoncer sahin exactement comme j'ai
fait des articles dans têtu pour
dénoncer le fait que dans l'est dans les
clubs y avait pas assez de prévention
je veux dire là dessus on a fait un
travail énorme et un moment erika était
plutôt du côté des teneurs de back room
parce qu'ils étaient super copain avec
eux alors qu'ils n'avaient pas assez de
prévention dans les sous-sols moi je
suis contre toute répression de la
sexualité
didier lestrade c'est un petit peu la
marine le pen des backrooms
donc moi je suis con je suis content du
système de répression
je suis je suis un révolutionnaire du
sexe un libérateur de la sexualité c'est
pour ça que j'ai écrit des guides sur la
sexualité ça fait 15 ans que je parle de
sexualité
là je sors un nouveau bouquin qui
s'appelle cqsgee ça fait 450 pages effet
des 405 novare explique aux hétéros
comment il mais j'ai aussi testé au
sexuelle je vous suggère ici c'est à
dire si un crédit faisait un bouquin qui
est logique et aussi aux hétérosexuels
hébergement donc tu me laisses parler
aussi nommé fait rire tout le monde
gérard faisant penser quoi moi j'écoute
pas je préfère parler de télé réalité
parce que on peu bavé sur star ac et la
ferme quand on entend ce que j'entends
je suis bien à terek hamac 10 moi je
baisse sans capote et je suis content de
le dire on ne peut pas inviter stéphanie
fugain pour parler de la leucémie on
veut pas parler du sidaction la semaine
dernière et laisser parler un mec non
laisser parler un mec je sais pas qui
ose dire moi je baise sans capote et
j'en suis fier et j'ai le droit de
penser
moi je trouve ça une honte et jls est
parfait
sans vouloir défendre avec la messe loin
de là mais enfin on peut aussi dire que
le meilleur moyen de roanne et c'est
bien des meilleurs moyens de lutter
contre le bareback c'est aussi dire que
bareback interroge un gars perros guirec
qui sait pas ce que c'est que j'ai
appris sur lui ce qu'il entend il entend
bareback que c'est parce qu ils ceux qui
croient que c'est un airbag qu un truc
de bagnols et à côté de ça il entend un
mec qui les dit baisse sans capote c'est
inadmissible ce qu'on entend là c'est
inadmissible ce qu'on entend là si on
doit le faire taire c'est inadmissible
[Musique]
érick rémy
oubliez toujours aux éditions pardon oui
moi j'ai juste une question c'est que
quand vous voulez vous être
question 6 mois ce qui m'intrigue c'est
bon c'est quand exemple j'ose dire que
si vous jouez avec votre vie c'est vrai
qu'elle vous appartient mais ce qui est
flippant c'est quand même de deux
peut-être
voilà je joue avec la vie des autres des
personnes un peu et innocente naïve fond
et c'est dommage que la vie cette
personne soit complètement voulzy après
quoi c'est ça
je conduis on va passer à votre butin je
crois que je crois qu en témoignant à la
télé en ayant le courage aussi de dire
ce que je dis est d'informer les gens
c'est une manière de prévenir
donc c'est a priori c'est votre gagne
pain et vous déguiser ça monsieur parle
de prévention vous fait du fric sur moi
c'est la prévention radical c'est donc
c'est dégueulasse sont radicales mais
non pas du tout en expliquant que tu as
fait les choses qu'il fallait vraiment
pas faire ça passe à la prévention avant
le grand soir au stade oui mais un roman
d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est
d'après jusqu'au condamne ce que
condamnent didier en racontant ce qui se
passe dans les backrooms moi je lui en
ai parlé il ya un an et demi en en
faisant un roman mais c'est la même
chose mais toi dans ta vie ça et si oui
est ce que tu sais que tu vas content
d'être contaminé d'autres mais moi je
suis mariée avec un mec qui cire est
négative depuis trois ans on est c'est
fait je n'ai pas contaminés mais il n'y
a pas de projet pas j'ai pas envie de
travailler depuis deux ans tu l'as dit
dans une autre interview faut savoir et
puis de toute façon on attend le bouquin
que tu as sorti sur le bareback c'était
il ya un an
et puisque tu as fait dans les années
précédentes déjà on va pas commencer à
te demander vraiment site a contaminé
les gens mais commence pas à dire que
c'est des trucs du genre c'est une
histoire ancienne
il ya des gens qui sont séropositifs
aujourd'hui et tu devrais tu peux pas
tout simplement considérer que c'est un
coup que tu as eue il ya dix ans ou même
un salut moi j'ai informé les joueurs ce
que je veux dire si tu t'es mon île si
vous avez des amis les gens souhaitent
une chirurgie pas content and day des
gens
ce que vous avez contaminer des gens
sciemment
ça m'avait parlé la nuit dernière sinon
comment tu peux dire et inconsciemment
non plus alors on passe à votre livre
avec rennaise donc ses excuses aux
éditions blanche or là ça s'adresse à
tout le monde
c'est un livre pan sexuelle ça s'adresse
aux hétéros et aux homos à tout le monde
derrière l'estrade se demande comment on
pouvait aussi bien connaître la
sexualité des hétéros ce que je pense
que pour bien faire un travail de
prévention faut bien vivre sa sexualité
qu'elle soit hétérosexuel ou homosexuel
il faut bien connaître les pratiques
sexuelles pour éviter d'avoir des
pratiques à risque voilà et donc moi
effectivement j'ai eu aussi des
expériences hétérosexuels je suis resté
trois ans avec une fille donc je connais
aussi les coûts de tous les côtés de la
barrière d'habitus et des médecins qui
écrivent des livres sur la sexualité de
sexologie s'est-il médecin mais
généralement monogame moi j'ai eu des
centaines de passagers ep20 400 à 450
pages en revue même moi j'ai appris des
trucs l'auto fellation par exemple le
taux national est léger au loto gens qui
tranche exceptionnelle
il a très peu de gens qui arrivent très
peu de gens auraient donc sur 450 pages
j'explore vraiment oui on va dire c'est
que je n'ai pas le sens mais j'ai jamais
la sexualité lot d oxydation antony tu
avais déjà entendu parler de ça non
jamais ne soit pouvoir une [ __ ] très
longues tresses fonction maîtresse ou
voix la vidéo tokyo nice tout monté
comme un hasard quand on a un peu des
deux ça marche noto fellation et notre
pénétration aussi des massages je parle
aussi beaucoup de physiologie parce que
comment comment masturber le point de
gesse de sa part 3 le point g comment on
pouvait connaître ça vous alors
qu'eux-mêmes et même les sexologues et
héros ils ont jamais trouvé les sexes
est réglé maintenant que le gps tactile
mais c'est vrai j'avais raison mais le
basque et bakambu cas je me dis il est
génial c'est à dire qu'il faut avoir une
grande habitude des femmes pour savoir
vous dites qu'il est entre tu lâchait
2,5 cm et 5 cm à l'intérieur que le sage
et il faut donc il faut pénétrer dans le
vagin de femmes ados et et relever la
dalle et en tirer relevé l'index de la
ferme il faut il faut comment comptent
ils commençaient à masturber très
doucement et c'est une petite zone qui
va de giroud qui va gonfler un certain
temps vous êtes sûr que ça existe c'est
celle qui a des grands sexologue qui
disent que ça n'existe pas le coin parce
que généralement la sexologie effet pas
départ des mecs et céphale au centre et
un don conséquent moins de la sexualité
des frais ahmed l'avantagent aussi que
j'ai c'est que comme je suis un mec qui
se fait aussi en tulle et c'est je peux
aussi comprendre la possibilité d'être
passif et récepteurs d'accord alors il
ya un autre truc aussi c'est le
cunnilingus
parce que oui ça s'appelle une coquille
qui rit on sait que c'est tant mieux si
les deux ont dit unilingue us également
ça me rassure parce que je crois que
c'est un autre truc moi je vous dit
peut-être le kiné l'ingrédient on peut
dire
les deux choses donc je m'occupe aussi
donc aux sexualités non pénétrent
hâtives
non parce qu'il n'ya pas que la
pénétration dans la vie donc redonner sa
place à des à des organes comme comme
lanusquets comment alors un organe
sexuel quelqu'un universel l'anus l'anus
la première oui je parlais de la
masturbation de la prostate une
masturbation de la prostate dont il ya
des diagrammes que c'est votre intérêt
comment vas-tu mange comment masturber
la prostate et c'est vrai que avec
l'état suédois avec un sur les doigts on
peut arriver à faire à faire jouir à
faire affaire éjaculer quelqu'un vous
voir le green et quoi justement de
chaque arrêt sans narration pesant un
peu de prévention quand même au milieu
de tout ça ça fera plaisir à didier vous
parler de ce qu'on appelle le liquide
séminal ça c'est très important parce
que le liquide séminal donc on ne dirait
pas peut être porter de voile à une
tournée tous les hommes n'ont pas de
liquide séminal donc c'est le liquide
qui vient avant l'éjaculation qui vient
au moment de l'excitation sont des
petites gouttes
assez assez assez épaisses des
présidents donc ça ça peut être
contaminants c'est pour ça on dit que
certaines que les fellations sans
préservatif peut être peuvent être à
risque même s'il n'ya pas une
accumulation d'un il faut se méfier de
celui qui a la balle et des femmes
fontaines ne l'est déjà rencontré des
femmes il ya on parle très peu
d'éjaculation féminine quand on parle
très peu de l'érection du clitoris mme
une femme ben d'autant qu'un garçon est
donc l'éjaculation féminine ça vient
souvent avec la masturbation du point g
quels mots tu as dit avant que les quoi
j'ai tord is history
je l'aimais entendez
alors les femmes fontaines c'est quoi
eric donc cessé un liquide un qui sort
comme une forte d'éjaculation qui
ressemble à de l'uriné c'est pour ça que
les femmes sont parfois très surprise de
ce liquide et les partenaires aussi
peuvent être gênés alors là il ya un
truc que je connaissais pas ces
l'infusion ce crotales donc la fusion ce
crotales c'est comme si je sens que ça
va me plaire
donc la fusion ce crotales en fait ça
consiste à remplir les le scrotum
d'arrêt de nantes et lui c'est parce que
c'est ce que le laisser les couilles le
sac d'élaborer la baisse des bourses
soit de liquide physiologique bon ça
c'est des partis avant s'injecte du
liquide du liquide physiologie ça gonfle
alors oui tout à fait ouais ça gonfle
c'est jouissif et ça fait jour certains
hommes mais ça c'est vécu après ça
s'évacue au bout d'un moment ça s'évacue
d'abord par l'apa la verge qui gonfle un
peu comme une canette de bière un moment
donc ça c'est vraiment ça donne des
idées divergent
heineken il y avait de la vie des
mineurs j'ai juste une question à lui
poser depuis le début qu'il est arrivé
ouais et l'amour dans tout ça quand je
vois non
il ya plusieurs chapitres qui sont
réservées à la communication à la
tendresse à l'affection à la sensualité
donc aux sexualités non pénétrent hâtive
donc comment parler d'amour
ces chapitres ces techniques ouais c'est
ça c'est vrai c'est un guide 1,5 ghz
alors c'est un guide pratique si
quelqu'un part d'en douter
il ya des publicités sur les réseaux ce
bouquin il est déjà autofinancer ses
incroyables
il ya au moins 40 pages de publicité
pour les réseaux là dedans moi je sais
pas si une nouvelle forme d'édition je
sais c'est le michelin de la [ __ ]
vraiment compris entre peinture et que
metz est devenu le bon samaritain de
l'amour tient comme un an vous vous
aider les gens à jouir vous fait de la
prévention
vous avez complètement retournez votre
veste d'une certaine lancé par un
retournement de veste ces données-là
l'information aux gens pour qu'ils
soient responsables de ce qu'ils font et
qui de ce qu'ils font avec leurs
partenaires dont qu'ils soient en accord
avec eux et avec les autres
didier ça doit vous faire plaisir de le
voir devenir comme ça le bon samaritain
de l'amour d'abord c'est pas un bon
samaritain et encore une fois c'est de
la merde c'est de la merde c c'est de la
merde parce que je dire on ne peut pas
tout simplement oublié des choses
quelqu'un tout simplement qui vous dit
j'ai baisé quelqu'un qui vous dit j'ai
baisé sens capable pendant pas mal de
temps et qui ose vous dire à la télé
j'ai pas contaminées où j'ai pas été
contaminé tout ça c'est quelqu'un qui
continue de mentir et dans ce cas là
vous n'avez pas besoin de croire ce qui
vous dit dans ce bouquin tout simplement
parce que la crédibilité rompu c'est je
veux dire à un moment on ne peut pas
faire comme si les choses qu'on dit
n'avait pas d'importance
on est tenu par ce qu'on dit dans les
livres précédents on ne peut pas dire
tout ça c'est du passé mais je suis moi
j'assume tout arrêter ce que j'allais me
ça va pas et s'il mérite voilà d'excusés
justement ce que j'ai fait moi j'ai
sorti serial croqueur en janvier dernier
donc ça fait un an et demi toi tu sors
ton bouquin que maintenant et trois mois
après j'ai sorti le guide du sexe gay
donc ça correspond à une entité ce que
j'ai fait entre serial fucker et le
guide du sexe gay c'est d'un côté monté
la montre et de ténèbres et de l'autre
côté montrer la lumière et moi ça
correspond aussi un cheminement que j'ai
fais personnellement à l'époque où j'ai
écrit serial fucker j'étais en pleine
dépression j'avais plein de problèmes
j'avais mon mieux mon meilleur que
pâques est en train de mourir du sida
après j'ai commencé l'analyse j'ai
commencé à faire un travail sur moi même
et je suis possible passez du côté de la
lumière c'est aussi cette lumière là il
a vu le jour dans le négatif et dans la
haine ton problème tu restes dans le
démissionnaire dépressif pas dépressif
je vous laisse juge donc cqsgee décret
mais les éditions blanche et dix ans de
didier lestrade chez denoël
je
grenet merci d'avoir été avec nous m'ont
soir
m
vous ne croyez pas sa rédemption
je crois que c'est de l'opportunisme ya
un boulot est ce que je disais au début
de conversation entre nous deux ça donne
une très mauvaise image de l'eau moscou
bah oui c'est bien triste
voilà je suis d'accord avant voyez
michel serrault dans la cage aux folles
maintenant on voit nos stades quang nam
il parle comme un taré yamagishi trois
générations oui mais c'est terrible bien
il ya quand même vincent mcdoom oui et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus